bad
welcome back to cbs mornings here at 8
30. we are very excited about our next
guest judge apatow he's the comedic
brain behind some of the funniest movies
from the past two decades
dozens of hits super bad knocked up 40
year old virgin bridesmaids and i'm just
naming a few if the scroll could be
endless really his new book is called
sicker in the head more conversations
about life and comedy it features honest
open and very funny interviews with
stars like david letterman mindy kaling
and pete davidson and judd joins us now
we're very happy about that yeah there's
a follow-up follow-up too sick in the
head which is terrific thank you the
only difference between sick in the head
and sicker in the head which is also
terrific is this is almost exclusively
pandemic conversation so a lot of it's
over zoom right that's right and gayle
king is in it
i don't know how she made the class
actually i went right
that's the first play i went i looked
for that section and you know
that's the only part i didn't read
i don't want to read i don't want to
read very well i mean i like to
interview comedians yes obviously
because that's what i do but also for
you know we have a few random people you
roger paltry you you're random no just
people who are you know in you know
media in the arts it was an interesting
mix it was an interesting mix i thought
it was interesting that you decided to
do it during the pandemic because you
said you wanted to laugh you wanted a
lifeline what were you trying to do well
also i just wanted to talk to people
yeah you're not going to talk to me for
two hours if i just go hang out you want
to talk for two hours i'm lonely
but i am writing a book
so it did give me an opportunity you
know to do another book and you know
it's for charity it's for dave edgar's
826 charity which provides a free
tutoring uh
underprivileged kids uh so
how else can i get lin-manuel miranda
and david letterman to talk to me and i
want to know the answers and to learn
something exactly that's the thing your
first book was your education and comedy
you started doing the interviews as a
teenager you're now a name in and of
itself in comedy are you still learning
things from these conversations yes yeah
i mean every every interview i'm trying
to figure something out like sasha baron
cohen i want to know like why do you do
that it's so dangerous and so
fascinating and actually how do you get
it done uh lin-manuel miranda i always
wanted to ask him after hamilton how do
you how do you not lock up how do you
not go i'm afraid to follow that look
how much he's done since then you know
so i'm trying to figure that stuff out
and i learned in that piece that lin was
in the sopranos i thought that that was
so interesting did you know i did not
know that
miranda was he said it was so bad that
you could see him physically looking at
to find his mark where he had to be
looking in the camera it was great you
know what also was i thought was fun
with every interview you also seem to
reveal something about yourself
because i went oh i didn't know that
about judge was that your intention too
well i you know i try to share my life
you know there's a autobiographical
aspect of the book and i think you know
when i share something about something
that happens to me then people share
sometimes when i'm doing the interviews
i'm sharing like a lot of the same stuff
to everyone i have to cut it out of some
of the interviews because i really i'm
interested in why people want to be
creative like you know what happened to
you that made you the kind of person
that wants to go into comedy so the
question of what happened to you is
actually an interesting one uh you
talked to gary goldman you did a whole
hour with him uh he talks about
depression and then in your conversation
with david letterman he points out that
they see the same psychiatrist yes also
depressed right so like i have to get
that number
please share it with the group with all
of us yeah that's clearly the guy
and then we just heard a hannah gatsby
talk about uh the pain that all could be
happening
so i mean is there something about
comedy and pain that is true or is it
just a cliche
i i mean i think if you come from some
sort of childhood trauma of some kind
you become empathetic you become a
watcher you also wonder why this system
isn't working for you and you start
breaking apart like what is happening
why is this all so hard and i think that
kind of builds a comedian's mind but you
also write without comedy you don't know
if you would have survived that you said
it were you going to say that yeah i was
going to say that because you know
because a lot of your characters in your
films and in your shows are in
situations that a lot of people would
find painful we were talking about
freaks and geeks and and the archetypes
of being young and being bullied but you
find the comedy in that drama
which is in some ways autobiograph
autobiographical with with what you've
experienced yeah i mean you know one of
my mentors is david milch who created
deadwood and he and he always had this
quote which i don't know exactly but it
is about turning the bad stuff into gold
and i think as a comedy person the one
good thing about it is when bad things
happen
you're not just bummed you're like this
might be useful this is uh this is
fodder for something and it doesn't make
life a little isn't that the mind of a
comedian in other words the rest of us
go well this sucks and then we go home
and we cry about it yeah you know we're
all depressed but that's what we do
right that's all we do comedians say
wait this is gold jerry
on the subject of gold we heard jim
carrey talk about the oscars last night
uh saying uh he thought hollywood was
spineless
and we should also say jim carrey didn't
come here to do that he was talking
about sonic sonic just like you came
here to promote man-made yes sicker in
the head
i'm going to promote sonic the hedgehog
right now
didn't cover it enough i just happened
to be here very very good
he said that he would have woken up and
sued uh will smith for 200 million
dollars another thing he might do is
wake up and write a set about the
experience right yeah yeah i mean
everybody handles those things
differently i mean we're concerned about
violence in all its forms and we don't
want to say to people when you have
conflict that's the way you do it so
it's great that he apologized because a
lot of people look up to him and they
aspire to behave like he behaves how do
you what's your response to how
hollywood is handling you know jim
pointed out that he got a standing
ovation that so far there have been no
consequences for will smith and how do
you suppose chris rock is feeling today
but i want to get your reaction to the
response hollywood's response to it so
far it doesn't really respond to
anything
so i mean if you just look at any issue
hollywood doesn't really respond i wish
i could say that they did
you think you should have been allowed
to stay in the ceremony uh i don't know
i don't have an opinion about that but i
just think like people really shouldn't
look for like the best moral ethical
response from the community of hollywood
and i'm part of it but i see them very
slow to to make any kind of a choice
i wonder though where do we go from here
as a comedian i just worry that
has a door been opened if you're you see
somebody saying something you don't like
that it opens the door to people think
well
it has happened will smith did it is
does it make it okay it's already a time
when people don't feel they can be
completely honest it's not okay to just
be wrong let alone be funny and and
distasteful in some way yeah well people
are on edge right it's been it's been a
hard couple of years you've brought hair
triggers yeah everybody's a little
afraid and it feels like that
is also part of what we're seeing
everywhere like everyone is just a
little off their their game but i think
his apology was great if people read it
i was glad he apologized and i hope that
people really didn't pay attention to it
because it is how we all should be
thinking about it i was very glad he
apologized and before you go what's it
like being mud
mod apatos dad right now yeah um
his daughter is on euphoria big star did
you know he's killing him
killing it i cannot watch it as a father
though because
it's very dark she's the good girl
that's what we like she's a good girl we
don't want to hear what next season is
but she's a good girl as to the end of
season two i mean we're so proud of her
the work is so strong and that the show
is so great and i was trending the other
day on twitter because no one knew who i
was and uh they kept people discovered
that i was maude's dad and then everyone
on twitter was like who's he
i thought well that means i parented
well because the next generation and her
and iris who's in the bubble or movie
that comes out this friday on netflix uh
they're better than me and leslie and
that's what we wanted appearances to be
surpassed yes leslie mann is your wife
yes he's amazing did you encourage your
daughters to get into this business
we're looking at mom and dad like little
yeah tiny pint-sized like i mean
it's weird because the reason why
they're in knocked up is i just didn't
want to hang out with other people
you know so it's either like some
strange person's children or my
which you could actually manage them a
little better exactly so i mean in the
beginning i was just like you know seat
belting them giving them bacon and then
they would just sit there while we did
scenes and they would just improvise
with us and now it's actual acting and
art and they've gotten very very strong
and you've been surpassed as you always
wanted well congrats
congrats to a great family and another
best seller for you is my prediction
because of the gayle king including yes
you know great comedic mind part time
yeah that's me
sicker in the head that title's
interesting too sicker in the head is on
sale now wherever you like to buy your
books and judd you're going to be at the
why's the 92nd street y this thursday
yes with romney yousef yes oh nice so if
you're looking for something to do in
new york there you go and his new
netflix film is called the bubble it
premieres on friday